on Wall Street the Dow Jones Industrial
Average will open above 20,000 points
today for the first time in history it
marks a major milestone since a low of
around 6500 during the Great Recession
of 2009
yesterday's record comes just a few days
after president Trump's inauguration CBS
News business analyst Jill Schlesinger
is here Jill good morning good morning
okay so what does this tell us about the
health of the US economy well it doesn't
tell us about the whole economy right
the stock market which is a
forward-looking indicator tells us
collectively that investors believe that
there are companies that are going to
keep making money in the future and
that's important of course a good
economy will help many of those
companies but it doesn't tell you
details it doesn't tell you long-term
unemployment or it doesn't tell you
people who left the labor force or it
doesn't tell you that people may be
working lots of jobs just to be where
they were 20 years ago it's good news
okay I don't want to go crazy here it is
good news I'd rather it be 20,000 than
10,000 yeah but it's not the whole story
but there's also the fact that if
there's tax reform there's two trillion
dollars overseas and if some of that
money comes back what will those
companies do with it well that's a great
point there I see three big issues that
have driven the market higher since the
election day and one is exactly that tax
reform on the corporate level let's say
these companies bring their money back
are they going to build lots of big
factories probably not might they hire
some people maybe what could they do
they could deliver more money to their
shareholders in the form of dividends we
have more money we'll reward our
shareholders if there's personal tax
reform that might actually help
wealthier people rather than the middle
class those people will plow money into
the stock market but and they have two
other issues that are important
infrastructure spending helps materials
companies if we get infrastructure
spending that could actually drive
companies higher and the last thing look
at regulatory reform the biggest winner
in the Dow since election day goldman
sachs if they're gonna water down
dodd-frank or change financial
regulations that's going to help banks
could help oil and gas companies as well
there are a lot of people that don't
have stocks are there implications
beyond the stock market well I think
that this is a really important point
because according to Gallup just 52
percent of a mirror
it's own stock either through their own
means through a retirement plan through
pension plans these people might be
looking at 20,000 and say who cares but
if we do see the economy improve and
pick up steam if more of these people
can get jobs change jobs more easily and
see bigger wage increases that could be
good Kodama take credit he said he's
very proud of the number well he can
take credit for the last nine percent of
the day but really he's came in after
the the indexes had already risen right
but look at the Dow Jones Industrial
Average it's off about two hundred fifty
percent if you include the dividends
since the bottom of March of 2009 most
of that happened right up until Election
Day this last nine percent we can see
whether that trump bump will continue
but that's Trump's part of it the rest
of it is really the legacy of the Obama
administration and just the general
economic recovery thank you